let's talk about journalists so record
number of journalists jailed worldwide
this is committed to protect
journalists its annual global survey the
committee to protect journalists found
at least 274
journalists in jail in relation to their
work on december 1st 2020 at exceeding
the high of 272 in 2016 china which
arrested several journalists for their
coverage on the pandemic was the world's
worst
jailer for second year in a row it was
followed by turkey which continued to
try journalists free on parole and
arrest new ones egypt which went to
great length you said egypt by the way
yesterday to keep custody of journalists
not convicted of any crime and then
saudi arabia which th this story doesn't
kind of help your story zooby but there
you go saudi arab journalists it's not
perfect okay countries where the number
of jail journalists rose significantly
include belarus where mass protests have
been short over the disputed reelection
of the long-time president
and ethiopia where political unrest has
degenerated into armed conflict within
the united states
no journalists were jailed at the time
of cpj
prison census exactly i can name two
yeah
an unprecedented 110 journalists were
arrested or criminally charged in 2020
around 300 were assaulted the majority
by law enforcement according to the u.s
press freedom tracker so
journalists is it a good time to be a
journalist or is it a bad time to be a
journalist or is it just where you live
dude one we need journalists we don't
have journalists anymore we have
political operatives that write for
periodicals we need actual
people that are fact finders that are
that are intellectually curious that are
uh politically agnostic or at least
professional enough to keep their their
bias uh to their side and be objective
in their reporting one of the biggest
problems that we have right now in the
country and i imagine in the world is we
cannot operate on the same reality
depending on where you're getting your
information you have a completely
different understanding of the reality
that we are living in and it goes back
to what you were talking about the left
versus the right i ascribe to something
called the horseshoe theory i don't know
if you could pull that horseshoe theory
okay it's it's not left and right it's
the north and the south on the spectrum
that matter more the libertarian or the
authoritarian if you're conservative for
your ideas that's fine as long as
there's no authoritarianism behind it
you don't force me into your
conservative ideas sharia law whatever
fascism all right if you're to the left
and you believe in equality equity in
egalitarian society okay great present
it and if it's a good idea people will
follow it if you force people into it if
you seize their property communism okay
so the further left and right you go the
closer those ideologies are okay the
further left the further to the left you
get away from the center the further to
the right you get away from the center
the closer they are communists and nazis
are much closer to each other than
people in the center of the spectrum
people either to the right of center to
the left or center have more in common
okay so that's what i ascribe to and
what we have now is we have people who
are making it they're justifying bad
behavior if anybody's ever read uh
alexander stolznich the the gulag
archipelago
it's the most important you talk about a
hero that book literally changed my life
it's a very dense book that book changed
my life because he talks about how
quickly it changes and as soon as good
men don't act evil wins every single day
and all that happens is it's well that
journalist was well that journalist was
a bad guy well he deserves it or or well
you know he shouldn't have written that
he knew what the rules why
why what is so wrong with this guy
writing something that you don't want
the world to hear let the world hear it
and let the let the ideas play out
you're repressing these people it
doesn't matter what your ideology is it
could have been christianity in the
1600s it could have been uh imperialism
it could have been communism whatever it
is as soon as you become authoritarian
in the nature you are in the wrong it
doesn't matter left or right
the problem is the problem is that well
firstly some people would disagree with
that last sentence which is part of the
problem right some people are very
authoritarian we've really seen that
come to light in the past year and a
half they really do they love authority
yeah and the another big problem is that
a lot of people just don't actually have
solid principles right and having
principles means sometimes you have to
defend
people and ideas you don't like or at
least the ability for them to be
presented out there and be presented
right so you know i think
i think aoc has terrible ideas i think
like you know i i i think a lot of ideas
are terrible but
i would never want you know someone to
be censored so like look at look okay
look at the response to gosh i mean
i think people still downplay how
significant this is i mean your sitting
president
got de-platformed from all of social
media back in january it's insane insane
right and people what's how do people
justify i don't like i don't like trump
right people let their emotions and
their feelings because they're not
principled right a principled person
even if you despise trump you can be
like i despise trump i think he's this i
think he's that but
he should be not not just because he's
the president but you know we were a
free country he should be allowed to
express his ideas he didn't break the
law he didn't right so
um you know there there's that but
because people allow like their personal
biases and their feelings towards things
to determine
who should be allowed to speak or what
degree or whatever that that's always a
problem because then you know people
have different ideas and ideologies and
belief systems
and
as soon as you try to like you said when
you try to force that on other people
that becomes the issue it's the same you
know people understand it i think quite
well with religion okay
so you know i'm a christian some people
are muslim some people are atheists
jewish etc there's lots and lots of
different religions and belief systems
and
you know you can espouse your belief you
can believe what you want etc if i you
know get on a horse and holding a bible
in one hand and a sword in the other and
i start want to go on some crusade to
start you know converting non-believers
i think people no you can't do that
right i want to strap myself with a
suicide vest and start blowing people up
crashing planes into buildings whatever
supposedly to spread
that that's that's the problem right
that's that's the line so
you can believe you can believe what you
want but if you're trying to force other
people to believe what you believe based
on force
that's the problem it doesn't matter if
it's political if it's religious
whatever
about a year ago when this whole thing's
taking place year and a half ago i went
up and i said uh
okay how are parents judged parents are
judged based on what
providing what a roof over your head you
know feeding you taking care of you but
you're also based on the behavior of
your children right behavior your
children how your kids react in school
okay great how was a how is a coach for
a basketball team or football team judge
whether they win or lose whether you win
or lose you know playoffs performance
getting better all of that okay how is a
coach of a college football team judge
how you the parents wanting you to want
to recruit all that stuff right how was
a president judge how is the ceo of a
company judge how is a sales person
judged
every one of us is judged this podcast
is judged based on what if we lose
viewers what they're saying is we don't
like your topic i'm going to another one
screw you great we're judge nonstop as
you run a podcast valuetainment is judge
if we don't do well we don't grow if the
topic's not good you do a podcast if you
don't give viewers they don't like it
you did great deal you do video gets
four million views on twitter guess what
the audience saying hey zubi do more of
these things we want to hear from you
right we're constantly judged however
how are journalists judged so i found
this article
and this article is society of
professional journalists okay
how they're judged is based on four
things
seek truth and report it go to the next
one
minimize harm okay
act independently
be accountable and transparent
that is the code of journalism go up let
me read a few of them go all the way up
go all the way up kai and let me read
some of these things here so let's look
at the first one here seek truth and
report on it journalists should
take responsibility for the accuracy of
their work very verify information
before releasing it okay that would have
already eliminated 80 percent of dossier
stories
we have an insider that's telling us on
on what is the word they use
unnamed sources that told us adam schiff
i've got this
original sources whenever possible
remember that neither speed
nor format excuses inaccuracy
provide context take special care not to
misrepresent or simplify promoting
previewing or summarizing the story the
headlines gather update and correct
information throughout the life of a new
story gather update and correct right be
cautious when making promises but keep
the promises they make so far
so far is anybody doing the left right
or middle it is anybody doing this right
every single valuetainer needs to take
this let me continue we're going to put
the link for everybody see this here
okay so next identify source clearly the
public is entitled to as much
information as possible to judge the
reliability and motivations of sources
next consider sources motives before
promising anonymity reserve anonymity
for reason for sources who may face
danger retribution or other harm fine
diligently seek subjects of news
coverage to allow them to correspond to
criticism or allegations of wrongdoing
avoid undercover or other
surreptitious methods of gathering
information unless traditional open
methods will not yield information value
to the problem and you see how this is
going right okay go to the next one let
me read the next one avoid stereotyping
go a little bit higher avoid
stereotyping journalists should examine
the ways their value experiences may
shift everything never plagiarize always
attribute okay so that's that part
minimize harm no no go up go up this is
the most important one label advocacy
and commentary
label advocacy and commentary what does
that mean to you that means stop
presenting your opinion as fast
okay minimize harm balance the public's
need for information against potential
harm or discomfort pursuit of the news
is not a license for arrogance or undue
intrusiveness so 80 of them are fired
okay 80 of them are fired okay show
compassion for those who may be affected
by news coverage okay
use high sensitivity when dealing with
juveniles victims of sex crimes and
sorts of subjects who are inexperienced
or unable to give consent
fine recognize that legal access to
information differs from an ethical
justification to publish publish a
broadcast avoid pandering to lurid
curiosity even if others do it you
realize none of this stuff
this is what they're held accountable to
and how they're judged i immediately go
to the kid wearing the maga hat who got
painted as destroyed yeah and they they
suited them
independently kai go up act independent
avoid conflicts of interest real or
perceive disclose unavoidable conflict
refuse gifts favors fees free travel and
special treatment be wary of sources
offering information for favors or money
deny favorite treatment to advertisers
okay that definitely doesn't matter
well that goes into your next story
about the ccp yeah let me continue here
on the last one then we'll go into that
story explain ethical choices and
process for to audiences respond quickly
to questions about accuracy clarity or
unfairness acknowledge mistakes and
correct them promptly expose unethical
conduct and journalism including within
their organization abide by the same
high standards they expect of others
by the way that's journalism okay from
1926.
that's changed in 95 years 30 years
later that's changed in 95 years so
when you go and talk about journalists
maybe some of this stuff by the way on
some of the countries you're talking
about like china you know turkey you
know saudi arabia or some of the
countries that they're talking about
look that's silencing is what they're
trying to do when you go and talk about
the government you cannot do that in
america you get a raise if you do that
right if you call on out the government
however that's journalism so if you
enjoy this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]